you brittany are on twitter now and i'm
going to tell you something you're much
better at being a pop princess at being
a sultry blonde that puts a snake around
your neck and actually i am a massive
fan as all my Ustream people know I
absolutely positively rock you all the
time so let me give you a piece of
advice I could be wrong by the way many
times I've been wrong in my life but not
about this
Britney you are making a mistake by
letting your Twitter be the normal
Hollywood mainstream [ __ ] what's
very important here is yes this is the
real Britney Spears your bio says ma you
can zoom in here if you want we've got
updates from her team her website and
yes even Britney herself no ma this is a
problem social media is about
authenticity and about real miss Britney
your tweeter tweeter as I call and
sometimes when I get angry like right
now it's not from your perspective
you're losing it it's just another PR
press release some when you say things
like oh my god seven hours until
womanizer premieres did you say that did
your team say that give your website say
that that is the problem idea I promise
you and every other real brand cuz trust
me me and all these other web
celebrities we're nowhere in the world
you will have millions of followers once
people understand what Twitter is but if
you want to dominate the Twitter game or
any other social media or even 2008 and
beyond the world it's got to come from
the heart it's gotta be real Brit and
everybody else who rocks into this world
so please do it yourself keep the team
let them do something else let them look
at some you know Twinkies or some hot
dogs or some you know jumping rope
whatever you want them to do but don't
let anybody control your Twitter make it
real make it come from your friend
because you know what if it was really
just you and it was really just you I
would follow that [ __ ] and I would
would hard but when it's your team it's
just a press release so I answer all my
emails and do all my own Twitter
don't let it get their bread you can
dominate this game you can win but
you've got to make it real that's all
I've got to say now I'm going back to
organizer